l'image de notre région est
indissociable des moulins au début du
siècle dernier on en comptait environ
800 le moulin du parent dit donc un
passé présent qui a résisté aux épreuves
du temps le travail du meunier est un
travail particulièrement physique il
doit déjà mettre son moulin au vent doit
pousser cette cette poutre la queue du
moulin pour les journées du patrimoine
quelques visiteurs ont fait le
déplacement à sang chaud bienvenu au
moulin du paradis patrick chauvin et le
président de l'association régionale des
moulins de beauce petit fils de meunier
il se fait guide en cas de besoin
alors là on est dans un moulin pivot
type et régionales un mois tout en bois
un moulin du xviie une nounou
qu'habitait son fils quand j'étais petit
je venais donc en vacances à 100 ch et
on croit que ça pas bougé depuis
c'était bien restauré la restauration du
moulin du paradis en 95 à coûter entre
250 et 300 mille euros ce moule à est
inscrit à l'inventaire des monuments
historiques depuis juillet 88 son
entretien
comme les 15 autres moulins restant est
un véritable chemin de croix
annuellement henry en restauration type
restauration ça nous coûte environ 2000
euros par moulin donc après on ne touche
plus un centime d'argent dead pour ces
petits travaux là c'est ce qui nous
pénalise un petit peu tous dans new moon
et si on fait passer petits travaux nos
moulins vont retomber en ruine de
nouveau la pleine de bosses est
d'ordinaire balayée par un vent qui dit
on rend fou mais parfois aussi souvent
et très capricieux avec le confinement
l'absence de visiteurs et de scolaires
le moulin du paradis a vécu un enfer